foreign
[Music]
number 19. today we're joined by a
fellow SOG veteran we've been friends
for over 52 years and uh we've had
different stories from SOG but this one
is like all the others truly unique in
nature and uh from time on the ground we
want to thank Jocko willing productions
for making this production possible
today and we just thank him and Echo
Charles and our staff for for getting
this online and getting our stories out
to the rest of the country today we're
joined by Doug godshaw Doug welcome to
the show Good Morning Jill how are you
good morning good and uh we first met
when you came back from my lock at some
point you came down to fubai I believe
and I remember we have a picture of you
and me at the camp Eagle launch site
with Tony Harrell many months later
but uh you had uh your stories are so
unique I like to start off if you don't
mind with uh because you're one of our
unique survivors from August 23rd the
day the sapper attack was on fob 4 in Da
Nang and we lost our 16 Green Berets
that day which is still the total worst
uh tragic loss for special forces in our
in our 60-year history but you were
there for that and uh so at the time
just to bring our readers up to speed
and August the 22nd they had a promotion
board
they also had a
the monthly meeting of the all the
different the commanders conference was
on August 22nd right and uh our
commander at mylock was there and then I
stayed over the command the so-called
promotion board was to be the 23rd of
August right and so the community at
that time we had six fobs so each
Commander was there correct and then
Clyde Sincere was representing fob 3
which was at mylock at that time correct
and so you come down for the promotion
board and you had a couple drinks that
night
yes I joined up with my friend John
Peters and my friend Bill brick bill and
I had come to Vietnam together from
training group we had a really
interesting short tour of training group
as you know indeed and uh bill was
stationed at fob for so he had a hoot so
John and I stayed in the hooch and John
and I took the advantage for the first
time of probably of having a cocktail in
in Vietnam and we went to the club and
had a couple of drinks
and then so after a couple of drinks
then
um at some point you and John retreated
back to your Hooch correct and the
weapons your weapons have been secured
like John's was secured we were very
safe we're doing everything correctly we
each had a 45
uh and we locked it up and Bill Brick's
locker with the lock with Bill Brick's
lock so we're completely uh sop with
safety of weapons since we knew we were
going to have a drink and uh so there we
were
all right so then
do you remember what is your time frame
for when you were really awakened by
explosives it's something like 1 30 or
two in the morning people differ on it
uh uh but it certainly was oh Dark 30
indeed and Bill brick was stationed
there so he grabbed his web gear and his
piece and he took off for the perimeter
where he had a post
and John Peters and I were sitting there
without a weapon because we locked up
our 45s in in the uh
uh Foot Locker I looked outside and for
the first time I saw a bad guy in in uh
very little clothes on with a headband
on with a satchel of explosives and they
were throwing the explosives around
we know now that most of the guys who
who passed that night died very early
they either died in the first round of
throwing the satchels or the first round
going into the hooches so I was very
lucky because they didn't come into my
Hooch and I watched them go by and then
we had to decide what the next plan of
action was going to be
so I met up with a young blonde
Lieutenant whose name I cannot recall
and he and I and later spider parks went
around we managed to find some weapons
and it could have been no neck
Lieutenant Lieutenant doll it could have
been
um very competent very nice we were very
careful we go to hooches go around the
corner take a peek look see what we had
we had some weapons by that and helped
help suppress uh
the the sappers and the other people
that came in there wow and um it was my
first time that I ever get shot at
welcome through the war huh correct my
God so would you wind up somewhere as
like one of the static positions after
you so you're like recalling
we were doing with the lieutenant and
later with spider spider says hey you
got to talk more about what you did Doug
because I was with you and we you know
were just suppressing the enemy
and then uh
the last last piece and remember that it
wasn't just 16 Kias there was additional
50 purple hearts we had 66
SF guys or people at that camp wounded
or killed I mean I forgot that never is
that right yeah it was terrible oh yeah
and we don't want to forget or a ditch
because the claim is that the bad guys
came in and put a machine gun the indige
barracks we don't know how many and
ditch were killed I mean it was bloody
so uh as as as Dawn broke uh the last
two sappers uh were in the shooter
and uh that they they left for heaven
after being in the shooter for a while
so that uh those were the last two guys
um
after that uh I'm a little unclear I
know I'm back on a helicopter to uh
mylock I knew Bill brick had been killed
I I think he was killed pretty quickly
right after the the sappers came in
right I think he took a burst pretty
early
and as you know we've been uh pretty
close to Steve over these years his
brother yeah that's been one of the uh
uh unique aspects of our relationship
with the family right right we met Steve
what now 15 years ago maybe it's been a
while he's been a couple of soas you and
I visited his house he's he's joined
your chapter for many meetings in
Southern California
and one of the we're sitting here at uh
the third group McPhee sag Memorial week
and Kathy and I went to the usosak
memorial and took a picture of Bill
Brick's name oh yeah some other pictures
instead of onto Steve absolutely all 16
names were there yes they are 16 and
right after that stay on seating right
yeah because uh I was out here for um
for another event earlier this year and
went down there sometimes you just stop
at that wall you see these names yeah
right so there's a thousand names there
oh yeah it's that many yeah and uh
starting with Korea sure and then we
talk about our guys and you just started
reading the name we forget well you know
I don't forget but I mean the deadly
toll of people that we lost yep during
that secret world which is the eight
year secret War
and uh you know uh you you brushed over
this quickly but your unique way of
getting into SF if you could go back to
talk a little bit about that how after
you went through basic AIT right you're
at special forces training group correct
and at some point to come out and say
hey you guys wearing glasses you you
don't qualify and they took you out of
the training and where'd you go from
there because
this is one of these unique Special
Forces stories I read an article a
couple years ago that I really liked and
it said you know Special Forces guys
when we started out in the 60s were
unusual we weren't like Rangers we
weren't like seals we were smart
and I know that Jaco is going to just
absolutely come over the top but we
thought outside the box and they said we
had different guys in there and they
talked about said we have guys with
glasses Rangers and seals don't have big
guys yes so uh yeah I bill brick and I
and Mike Morehouse were all at training
group we we started training group in
those brand new Barracks as we talked
about right it was my second time at
Bragg I'd done basic here and uh a medic
from the dispensary calls me down and
says uh private yeah you have glasses I
said yes sir I said something else but
um I've had glasses since fourth grade
he says well how could you you know run
missions Behind Enemy Lines if you have
classes I said I have a spare and I'm
not that damn blind uh anyway we were
thrown out for having glasses in today's
special forces they'll they'll operate
you all on your eyes to improve your
vision really yeah I want to sign up I
can use some help exactly I read about
15 years ago if you qualify and you make
it through the selection process and
they'll do an operation on your eyes
anyway so we we still all wanted to go
to Vietnam we we went through Oakland
Bill brick and Mike Morehouse and I and
uh wound up in Benoit and we're sitting
there on that stifling heat and a first
lieutenant Green Beret comes up and
talks to us and says do you guys still
want to be in Special Forces we said
hell yes
so we got the orders to go to the track
the headquarters of the fifth group and
when some something called the
course command orientation course only
the Army could call it the course
is that what the title was yeah in 68
yes yeah okay and it was a three-week
course and most of the guys went to sog
uh Bill Badger an Infamous member of RT
Louisiana oh wait Dave Badger a Dave
Badger yeah infinite an Infamous person
uh but uh and and other people and we
went to SAC so I went to fubai First had
a cup of coffee with a hatchet Force
there and then went to Milo so I came in
country July 10 and I'm in the train
like July 12 13 14 15. yeah three weeks
uh beginning of August go to fubai and
then to my lock which was my PCS with uh
with a major sincere my first Combat
Commander and then it was from there
that uh
we went to uh Danang for the infamous
stupid uh promotion board I remember
talking to Roy Borat saw her a couple
years ago the the late Roy bar the great
Roy bar indeed and uh I said you got to
tell me sir what was the purpose of that
that promotion board he said it was
pretty damn stupid I mean there's no
reason to have it you know if you were
in the upper racks trying to try to get
it promoted to E7 or E8 that's something
but PFC to spec four I mean that's a
rubber stamp okay oh yeah I never
appeared before promotion exactly I
never appeared before I never appeared
for one in my entire time in the Army
yeah it was supposed to but I didn't so
anyway that that was the promotion board
um as you know we were honored uh three
years ago at soared to present to the
families of those who had fallen on 2368
a very nice program
which were helped by Body Cooper and
Eldon bardswell and spider Parks were
sure and you gotta you put it aside your
Mossy for a moment this was a special
operations Association of which you're
now duly elected president sir until
impeached yes sir until the pizza
indeed but you know uh we got back up a
little bit talk about your fob 3 because
earlier in 68 fob3 was located at
caisson correct as on the western
perimeter I believe of the historic case
on battle with the Marine Corps I
believe it was the West Wall yes and so
they were running missions out there
when caisson was closed uh we still
needed that operational base up there
classes here went out and opened my lock
which had no perimeter and when you got
there what was it like besides muddy
that was just mud there's a one picture
of me with a tent with no shirt on and
I'm having a cigarette and I remember
going into whatever the closest Bill
wasn't buying a bamboo mat okay because
that's what I slept on really yeah
we had a cook who was uh I don't know
what his English was like but we had a
cook and that's the only staff person I
think we had was a was a cook why they
picked that place I don't know because
as you know right next door they were
building an A-Team the other was an SFA
team at mylock that they were building
you know structures for we didn't get
okay there was just nothing there
why they put it there I don't know it
was a short Chopper ride from the case
on that's all I can say it's still close
to Route 9 in the DMZ and Laos and and
the targets across the fence yes exactly
indeed it was a launch site really I
mean it really wasn't fob it was just a
place for helicopters to land well yeah
and uh uh we and they started to do that
perimeter and that was when they had one
of those tragedies when they were
putting Minds out that we lost one of
our uh soldiers there with a Bouncing
Betty yeah we lost Gary Matson and um
you know there's there's uh Jeff junkins
was with him and uh that that kind of
messed him up too oh yes of his life
absolutely oh yeah that was horrible I
wasn't there that day but uh you know I
came back and they said be very careful
I think junkins was trapped in the
Minefield for a couple of hours he
landed on top of one yeah and then the
the team members came out were able to
get him off it without being right I
just can't imagine well it was it was uh
was a dangerous place if you want to get
out to Route 9 it wasn't that far as a
couple of miles but you had to take mine
sweepers out he had mine sweepers and go
ahead of the deuce and a half's to get
to route nine to uh wow it was it was it
was primitive indeed room nine was one
of the major highways that was yes
indeed parallel and DMZ and uh
there was that uh oh so while you're at
mylock at some point you run into
another spec four
I I ran into a three uh four interesting
people including you
um but I ran into a guy named Eldon
bardswell he came out a little later
than I did I ran a mission uh with uh
Recon team Georgia Tom Cofield in San
seating this year after I got back from
23 August 68. really right away right
away yeah
and we went into that was your Cherry
Mission that was my Cherry Mission we
went to an AO in Laos which I learned
later no one had lasted a day we lasted
five days all he heard was warning shots
and then you know I'm the little man on
the totem pole oh yeah in the pick 25
I'm the one too and we were in our Ron
position waiting to be extracted on the
fifth day we had IFR weather the weather
was terrible
well we got overrun this is the second
time in a week I got overrun I would no
overrun God shall don't don't hang out
with me bad thing happened we estimated
reinforced platoon came up with a hill
we had an Arvin Sergeant there and we
think we fell asleep
Tom Cofield beat himself up for the rest
of his tour of Vietnam and we suffered
some horrendous casualties Stan seating
was killed
we had the urban Sergeant was killed
much of us were wounded and the
helicopters these is this is another
story of SOA is just not Recon teams
right maxag is just not Recon teams
absolutely we're all alive today thanks
to them right well they they navigated
to our position in Laos by hitting their
skids on the top of the trees was too
slicks no gun ships no cobras no a1as no
no cover whatsoever to come and get us
and we had to and you're under Fire
we're under Fire and I'm dragging Stan
and we're trying to get the rest the
team there and they came there and the
world famous Chase medic Dicky was on
the this was on the door that's Dickie
Crawford Dicky Crawford yes and I kept
telling him take care of Stan Stan had
been shot right away and he was dead I
knew it but dick Dickey uh kept telling
me don't worry about there's nothing you
can do wow so we uh
we flew to Quang 3 because we had some
injured Brew
Kumbaya was had a hole in his shoulder
you could see through so we went to the
Army hospital in Quantum tree and they
wouldn't treat him because he was
indigenous so we convinced the staff
that they really ought to treat them or
die we locked them loaded and said we
need to take care of this guy so they
did
oh my God then we came back to Quang 3
excuse me came back to my lock and uh uh
I discovered then that I had some
shrapner on my shoulder and arm and uh
Robert shippen medication sure he uh he
took uh some shrapnel out of various
pieces of my shoulder and left arm and
and wrapped me up in a bandage I look
like uh I don't know he looked like he
took all the bandages he had and wrapped
me up looked like 10 pounds of bandages
and Roy Barr flew it
from fubai because he'd heard about you
know we did this disaster and uh I said
how are you I said sir I'm just fine
there's there's nothing here and
shipping said no this is a real I said
we're okay okay we're just fine
uh forward story is I I refuse to take a
Purple Heart right and actually my dad
did the same thing in World War II in
the Navy is that right 250 people and
his ship killed he said I'm not taking a
purple
on his chest
so about six months later I'm in Da Nang
yeah with Dickie and uh
uh they're they're there's some very
nice people nominated me for a civil
stock Silver Star they gave it to Stan
seating which is the right thing to do
for his family that we lost him and I'm
in Danang with Dickey walking up the
main drag and he said you didn't take a
Purple Heart
I said sir you know Stan was killed when
the arm guy was killed coomba had a hole
through me I just had some shrapnel and
he said one of these days and I can't
tell you the whole story but one of
these days you're so ugly but you might
find some woman who likes you you might
figure out how to make children and your
children should know that you are
wounded so my purple heart says Sergeant
God saw because it was given six months
later right that's all you've been
promoted yeah without a promotion board
right and with glasses and with glasses
and I had those ugly gray glasses oh
they were a stone you and Tony had those
ugly glasses those were those are the
biggest prophylactics the Army could
have
want to date anyone with those stupid
glasses and then fast forward many many
years yeah Eldon bardswell found me
because we had we both were on the same
Purple Heart orders he got his first
Purple Heart on the same Waters I got my
only purple heart oh in April 68 and uh
and so forth well back to Eldon
everyone's favorite E4
he showed up in mylock spent a cup of
coffee there because he was only there
we were there in August and we shut down
December I mean it wasn't even a year
that it was there
and then I got to know him better in
Danang when he was running teams he was
running RT Michigan I was a strap hanger
all the time
RT Georgia was didn't have a 1-0 for a
long time and I ran a couple of missions
with him he was uh
a tremendous athlete I mean really a
good athlete oh it's a star half back in
high school I think he played football
in college and he could run like a deer
and he never forgot anything if you told
him something he never forgot he had a
fantastic memory
and uh sometimes that was really a
liability he was but he's also a little
superstitious as I said since we all
were you know yeah absolutely here's
here's my issue he says if I take your
picture you live everyone who I take
your picture of they survive I said take
my picture so there's a bad picture that
Jason Hardy has of me standing looking
I'm 21 I look like I'm nine standing in
the Recon company with a stupid hat on a
stupid smile and those stupid gray
glasses oh my God and uh Jason already
found that
ran a couple missions with Eldon and um
you know he's the legendary Sonic
Soldier oh yeah for
he finally called me up in late August
one store which still was September and
he said is this Doug Godshall and I'm
thinking you know what's this guy trying
to sell me was this yeah God's own
special force in Vietnam yes sir he said
this is Elvis Elden how are you he says
you got to come out to SOA I said what's
SOA
and uh I had just won tickets to the
Ryder Cup in a lottery it was in
Kentucky and and uh I gave the tickets
to a client of mine a friend of mine go
out I came out to SOA and uh cleat was
the president yeah and he said welcome
home and Eldon uh couldn't have been
nicer to me got to see you
and Alden was on the board then too as a
director I think I think he was uh troll
came up to me everyone remembers troll
George Sternberg indeed Saw cast number
one exact was he he should be yeah and
he said you ran with Elton didn't you I
said yeah he says welcome home yeah no
kidding yeah it was it was very
interesting and I met Robert shippen you
know who had stitched me up indeed and
then so when I brought my wife out a
year or two later to the next store
shipping ratted on me
he told Kathy that I had to be escorted
to my room because I'd probably been
over served
Kathy said you stink her anyway no
I said ship and you're the stinker
indeed you're writing on your buddy here
indeed there's some things that should
stay in my life exactly stay away
so when uh so when you ran a couple of
targets with Elton he was the one zero
at that point correct yeah okay
so you learn from the master
yeah and Tom Cofield was a Google great
guy 1-0 there was a guy named Andy whose
name I can't remember we went to a
mission to DMZ with Andy he was a good
guy as I said I was a strap hacker after
he lost eating we had an incomplete team
uh I went TD White and Abby to it for a
month ran with a guy named Gregory
grandison a 1-0 there so you they picked
you up and sent you there by yourself
without a team or anything correct oh my
God right and I was talking to uh
see Captain Harrison who's here today
Randy Harrison Randy yes yeah he was the
Recon company commander and and uh I'm
trying to remember the name of the other
guy I ran with I'm still the one to
ran a mission with uh Granderson who was
a good guy good another blonde hair
officer into Cambodia it was so flat it
was lovely you know oh yeah no up and
downs great on your knees
then he got sick after the first mission
which was I think it's the only Mission
I was on that we never got shot at
we hit we're set for another mission and
uh this E5 who is the 1-1 ran the team
so we got inserted near the Big River in
Cambodia we're not supposed to know him
no name of the Big River it was the meat
gone indeed doing a river watch and we
were on this little island and
um uh I didn't know it then but this E5
had never been out before that was his
Cherry Run and he's the team Commander
now oh wow because he was there and you
weren't exactly you're a strap hanger
even though you got worlds of experience
that's all right yeah so we see this
boat out in the middle of the river and
it's got a big damn gun on us about a
30-foot boat Patrol boat and it's got
like the equivalent of a 50 caliber on
it and it's going the opposite way from
where he came in we came on the waist of
this island it was a little path it
wasn't that far from the mainland maybe
out of the Yards
and I said to this guy I said uh if that
boat turns around they found us right
there it's only been about an hour since
we we infiltrated since we landed yeah
and we make a lot of noise you know
people say how how did they find you
well helicopters make a shitload of
noise
and uh sure enough the boat turned
around starts heading toward our Island
and uh so I turned to my my team leader
and I said okay what are we going to do
and he's sitting under the tree shaking
oh no he completely flipped out
he couldn't handle it
so I took over the team I split the team
against all the rules indeed uh put my
best uh Mountain yards out on the point
where the boat was coming with some
Claymores and I thought they'd also
attack us from the from the land on the
waste and I got lucky so I took that
piece there I took some soldiers there
and we were very lucky got all all my
guys out they landed in two places and
none of my guys suffered a scratch wow
and uh the claymore's worked on the boat
the claymore's worked on the guys
getting off the boat we worked on the
other side with the car 15s and the
grenades and then uh
uh so we're waiting now I called for a
verifier for an extract and curly got on
the phone
the commander of bammy Tuit who is a
well-beloved guy who was a
follicly challenged and
he said
whoever this is I I want you to continue
the mission Charlie Mike I said Sir with
all due respect I cannot I didn't tell
him my team leader was paralyzed and
useless and still sitting by a tree
chattering and uh so we came back to
bammy to it
I just told the colonel never send this
guy out again that's all I got to say
don't happen don't don't do that and we
are also in addition to Riverwatch we're
supposed to do in a snatch he wanted to
you know everyone always wanted a pow
always always so he made fun of me at
dinner at the uh at the mess hall last
night you know God so came back and he
didn't get a prisoner and we're gonna
get one next time in a good natured way
yeah of course but uh curly curly Maple
made me stand up and say Here's another
failure he didn't get a pow but
that was I ran two missions and pay me
to it it was a nice place oh
yeah because I I never got there I was
just down to honak till which is fob6
and still they so the idea was they're
just gonna put you on the island you're
gonna watch the river and those and
you're only out there for an hour and
your cover's broken and here they come
we'll hit 50 caliber yeah
look at this guy say oh my God what are
you doing there you know so
so from there you go back at some point
you wind up at fubai then they close
fubai uh I think I went directly from
bammy to it to the Nang it was around
Thanksgiving Christmas and
um my lot closed at some point I wasn't
there when the uh
Infamous Mission with the crummy
ammunition went into a lot November 30th
November 30th I was not there then so I
know I I know I had Thanksgiving plus
one of those little moments in time we
were talking about that as the last
reunion right you're down to fob F5 is
that F will be six and we all came home
after that uh kingb crash with it got
shot down right with 7sf on it and then
the uh
they were later able to recover them and
they were also they I think is that the
one where they also buried the kingb
crew with the Americans
I'm not sure about that I know that uh
when we were burying uh the successor to
our team Michigan in in Arlington 10
years ago or whatever it was
um Billy Brown and guntherwald and Brian
shu that Eldon took us of a tour of
Arlington and there's a memorial to
those guys in Arlington the memorial of
those guys on the Divide who died on
November 30th 1968 when they were shot
down well I should shot up whatever yeah
and but there was one I there was one I
think Air Force guy
his family never believed that you know
their their son was killed they couldn't
get his remains or remain satisfactory
he was very sad but there is a there is
a memorial right and just for
um our listeners on November 30th we had
an 834 South Vietnamese Air Force
kingbee that was uh flying towards Laos
or maybe actually over layoffs at the
time who had gone across the fence and
the mission was an elder son which was
to insert uh ammunition that was rigged
to explode right when the enemy used it
and so as a volunteer mission
and with seven
um
SF men on it and uh
that might be Rob real
and then uh in Ruth they get shot down
and we had the the
muskets were flying escort
and uh bird Garland was one of the
witnesses that saw it get hit and go
down yeah and they came back and uh in
our case we got we were literally in the
field
and they pulled us out and said you got
to get back to fob one
and uh that was why and so I'm assuming
you went right back too because of the
same reason I I don't know what I read
but I'm pretty sure I went from bammy to
it directly sure spent the rest of the
69 until I went home in Da Nang so when
you land at the Nang you're a strap
hanger
we're back on Georgia okay they were
always trying to find a 1-0 for Georgia
and they had a couple of candidates that
didn't work out and um but I would do
strap banging in between
I wanted to be active there was always a
couple of guys
who were giving me a hard time because I
didn't graduate from training group and
uh so while you're there oh yeah so I I
always said I'm gonna try to run as many
missions as I can and just prove that
I'm I'm doing the job Indeed period so I
I did a lot of strap hanging uh the last
week on Mission I ran was the infamous
Dewey Cannon which you know all about
listens a little bit about that because
that was a
hellacious Sideshow well from a command
point of view it was a total cluster
indeed we were
a battalion-sized operation which SF
never did let alone Mac B sod on the
west side of the ash out in Laos yeah
and as you know the ash eye value is
probably the most dangerous area in
South Vietnam
we had an 18 to the the base had been
wiped out three we had three eighties
wiped out yes sir horrible
so and the Marines were on the east side
they were on the uh
VN sort of the border and we were sort
of a blocking force and sort of tried to
push the the bad guys towards the
Marines where they can wipe them out
so there was uh Lieutenant Armstrong had
one of the companies he had a Brew
Company I forget who had the other
company of indige
I'm pretty sure Dan Thompson was on that
mission too but I could be wrong but I
know Mike Armstrong was but right that
was I was running point for the uh
you're running points I was running
point and we're on the top of a ridge
and and if you're in a two-company
operation you're always going to be in a
fast Trail I mean you can't go through
the woods like right on the you know
10-man nine-man in uh Recon team
so I found that the top of the ridge a
little cache of enemy supplies maybe
twice or three times the size of this
desk there was some rice there was some
Combs there were some uniforms
and the infamous major war was the
commander no and uh so we stopped and we
call them up and um and he said well I
want you to destroy this cash as
sergeant gachow I said sir that's not
that's not that wouldn't be my choice
uh we make too much noise as it is I'm
used to being on recon teams we don't
talk for five days yeah talk about break
and hand signals and all that and he
wants us to destroy this cash which is
going to make too much noise
and uh and they'll be smoke so anybody I
can sight in for artillery why don't you
just tell them where the hell we are
excuse me sir but anyway I didn't say
that say that I'm sure I didn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't that brave yeah but
anyway it was my turn to be relieved
from the point and we know what happened
afternoon the team that took over the
point was uh the guy another guy on from
Pennsylvania he was from Pennsylvania
from Montgomery County and took over the
point in about 150 yards walked into an
L-shaped Ambush and got wiped out whoa
and uh so instead of doing anything we
sat there one there was there was a nun
company in addition to the Brew Company
there was a Chinese nun company we sat
there for a few days just sat there and
that enabled the bad guys to zero in
their their their mortars so at seven
a.m at 7 A.M here here's the incoming we
dug in
um they were very good I mean they had
within a foot of my uh of the whole line
Doug wants and all the dirt spread out
no one got hurt but after a few days the
engineer types got some C4 and blew some
of the trees down to make a an LZ so
that we could get out of there somehow
they'd made a termination we weren't
going to go forward I don't know why I
would have rather going forward kept
moving yeah and just you know keep
moving watch out we had a large enough
force that we could we could handle
ourselves
so late one afternoon the first
helicopters come in
and later on I got the story because I'm
I'm still uh maybe I'm a sergeant then I
don't know respect for but um
the first one who left the LZ was Major
more
he was the commander he got on the first
chapter they had a temporary LZ in
Vietnam set up and it was an 06 waiting
there now I don't know where this 06 was
from I didn't wear some Saigon but he's
waiting to you know greet us there and
we came out on big choppers and major
mortgage off and the 06 supposedly said
I've never been more shocked in my
professional life to see the commander
and be the first one to step off the
exfiltration oh my God I got out later
that day uh they didn't get us all out
that night the nuns started walking away
and we got everyone out the next few
days and I saw a major Moore in Danang a
few days later saying well see you later
I'm going back to the States so he got
relieved of any further duties in
connection with the war and went home
because this was the same major war that
on August 22nd
he was told and days before the released
three transmissions saying attack
imminent we think so but we're not sure
not 100 sure if you get on I'm not much
on Googling stuff but there's pages of
stuff on Dewey Canyon from people who
were officers or commanders uh at that
time not me who wrote information about
Dewey Canyon but uh we we think it's the
same major more but we do not know that
yeah I do not know that
indeed we can just deal with the facts
here don't put the facts sir and then
after that I went to uh uh I got to meet
Mike Armstrong wonderful wonderful
officer wonderful man and he asked me to
be the first sergeant on the hatchet
Force which is a big deal for being the
only other American he was the commander
he was a first lieutenant or a captain I
was a sergeant and the ransom had I
remember talking to the
the senior ncos and they said Doug
you're still going to go out with
missions I said that's fine I just want
to go out with a guy I know who's a good
leader uh we did somebody you trust
somebody I trust the one zeros that came
through Georgia did not work out
uh one of them uh this is one of my
wife's favorite stories
was a young Lieutenant a cherry
and his father was a lifer and this guy
was gung-ho
so he's going to be the 1-0 for Georgia
we go down to Saigon
and we get briefed by a two-star Air
Force Guy where are we going well we're
going to go to the Northwest concert at
Northwest Quadrant of mujia pass the
main pass from North Vietnam Trail
may have some pretty good high
resolution fixtures you could see 55
gallon drums yeah on the ground what's
in the Southeast Corner well as a
battalion of troops what's in the
northeast corner well as a battalion of
troops well what's in the southwest
corner there's some troops there too
what about the Northwest water well we
don't know that's why you're sending us
why we're sending you there sergeant
lieutenant
and uh I said well have we had any teams
going there well not any teams with
Americans we've had Indigo in with those
radios let's have punch for tank punch
for troops and so forth yeah yeah what
they find well they didn't come out I
said with all due respect sir I know
who's in there it's my buddies from the
fifth NVA Panzer Division that's who's
in there that place is full of bad guys
okay
so how did you know that
also the the indigenous teams and don't
come out
then uh so he came back to Danang and
we're running a training Mission with my
new one zero and I talked to the Brew
they weren't going out with him
they weren't going to go out with the
Cherry one zero right so we had a little
training Mission
um helicopter tipped a little bit and he
got pushed a little bit out of the
helicopter nothing very high but just
for about 10 feet just you have to break
a leg or an ankle and we did not go out
with him
oh my how these unfortunate accidents
unfortunate accident yes it was very
unfortunate I hope I hope his Orthopedic
injuries went well indeed well so you're
juggling hatch of force Duty and at that
point do you finally become the 1-0
foreign
school I just want to run missions and
uh you know be a contributor it's like
just like the Doug Doug Eternal same
same just go yeah oh my God so you wound
up going in with the hatchet force with
Armstrong What kind of missions were
they there was we never hear much about
the hacker well they're more more of an
Attack Force when you're looking for
something to attack them I know that on
the last mission again we're looking for
p
trying to make it
so we're big enough that we could uh you
know deploy a squad or two to you know
he uses a minor blocking Force if we
found a guy
um we didn't
uh one of the most interesting things I
ever did in Vietnam was in our last
Hatchet force uh Mission we were
probably in South Vietnam right on the
border but the Navy had a program they
wanted to use their battleships
and the USS New Jersey sure was offshore
and I talked to a lieutenant fact from
the Navy and we called in a Firepower
16-inch rounds from the New Jersey it
was the stupidest thing why would we
call 16 inch rounds into the triple
canopy jungle what was the point of that
you know we had to walk him in from a
click away we had to start away from uh
right oh sure and uh you know we were
never sure where the we were anyway
and on the ground so we walked it in and
I called in uh
Firepower from the New Jersey and
May or June of 1969 but yeah I can't
imagine that fireplace so did it ignite
at the top of the Triple Canopy or did
the country went through it penetrated
through it and made a big big sound big
sound oh yeah I can remember hearing
them go overhead it sounded like a
Volkswagen going over your head and they
also when they fired those off those big
cannons and by the way you know the New
Jersey's in Camden New Jersey now is
that's it's a permanent yes your native
state my my grandfather's native state
and uh when they fired those guns they
fired Blanks on the other side
so the ship didn't tip
so that's a little factor I never knew
yeah yeah see so
McPhee's side was helped by the Navy
that day indeed
did you actually have any enemy to shoot
at we just fired some fire for effect no
idea my recollection is very poor on
that but I know we we probably had some
guys we had some bad guys we're trying
to fire up and I I would have chosen
other ways to do it well there aren't
many Saw guys that could say I called in
the the USS New Jersey on a 16 inch
rounds oh my God yeah because they're
like 2 000 pounds yeah they were they're
a big suckers yeah they're a little
bigger than the NATO around just a
little is that right yeah
well you got this Navy background that's
that's fascinating you got those details
I never knew that because they fired
then they fired Blanks on the other side
to keep a bounce on the ship otherwise
it would have rolled over it would have
rolled I think it rolled over but
there's
those are some big big explosions when
those suckers leave the camera so uh so
you and Armstrong did a couple missions
with the hatchet Force yeah we did uh
two or three something like that because
I got on the hatchet Force like February
March yeah my D Rose was in July great
guy wonderful man
and in between you come back to do
anything more with the RT Georgia no I
passed them on I said we know we got to
get a uh you know we got to get the team
up to strength with Americans you need
to qualified 1-0 and they continued on I
know I know they did missions in 70 and
71. our teachers sure because I remember
them in Camp after after that mission uh
when Tom was the one zero that you were
on right and there was that question at
one point we had do you remember Henry
King yes and Henry was from Georgia we
kept saying you hear me you know this is
perfect you're from Georgia right you
should be the one zero and he was like
no no I don't want one zero Duty right
right and then uh neither did I yeah so
when he said no uh we took him out on
Mission with us
and he took he took the experimental
pump m79
and he took that but he carried all this
ammo and the second day were on the
ground we climbed this mountain all day
and then we got near the top Henry goes
can I get rid Barry a couple of rounds
because he was beat but he was strong oh
yeah he's a big strong guy great guy
yeah yeah and he ran like you he ran
many many teams other teams into us as a
strap hanger yeah but that's doesn't
decrease the danger at all
no there's a piece of strap hanging
that's not smart because you've not
worked with the team and you're not sure
what the guy is going to do Under Fire
but I'd been I'd been on a number of
teams and other missions so I was I was
considered reliable I wasn't good well
you were you had a good one right you
had a good reputation and you know the
little people talk behind the scenes
because they would go who's this guy and
they would go to the team that you had
been on or been out with so your
reputation was Rock Solid there well
that's why we had that issue with the
new one zero and we talked to the Brewer
that we weren't going out with him
we came up with a plan
so of all your targets with Georgia what
was your worst Mission and which one
comes to mind well I think the worst
Mission has got to be the first one with
Tom yeah the one with Tom and Stan
seating I mean Stan was killed right
away it was horrible we didn't expect to
run over I just come back from 23 August
and uh
uh that was just that was just horrible
sure I mean there were bloodier missions
there were more casualties on other
missions but
Stan and Thomas treated me so well
indeed so at some point you turn around
you come home I did
I got I I had
you know I didn't know what was getting
into in July of 68 but by July 69 I was
treated very well yeah and the when I
left they said we'd like to give you
your rest do it signation on the MLS I
turned that down because I still had an
attitude yeah you you didn't want
to give it to me you threw me out of
training group I ran missions here asked
me to go to OCS
and I turned that down and uh years
later when I talked to Eldon
because I'd seen him once or twice in
brag in my last year right and he said
you turned down an S designation I said
yes he said that was a stupid
thing to do
I said yes it was elder man it was
stupid that was a mistake on my part
so live and learn he is Cliff Newman got
me orders later on there's a lot of guys
early in the history of sfd didn't go
through his training group right the bad
tolls group sure and Cliff Newman was
one of them Clydes and Sears another one
he said you're qualified I'll get you
ordered so that you can get the special
forces tab in lieu of the fact that you
were such a dumbass and didn't get the
yes so well you're a busy everyone
misses too it wasn't like you're sitting
around playing Tilly Wings right anyway
but it was very it was very nice and
Cliff and Eldon took care of me and I
got those very nice orders well yeah and
and the uh one of the sidebars to that
is
the missions were so difficult we lost
so many people we did that by 68 we were
recruiting from other Airborne units
like we had a guy that came over from
the 173rd ran a mission with us Mike
Krall check came in from 101st Louis
SATA from 173rd yep absolutely yeah no
we and that that's why Mike and I and
Bill were recruited also we are 11
Bravos we've gone through infantry
training as you know you didn't have to
have infantry to be in training group
but right if you had infantry trading it
helped it would help and we we'd been
through jump school so Clyde and I had
conversations later many years later and
he said yeah I was always looking for
people we lost uh 68 you know SOG
average two wounds a piece all of us
average two wounds I had one oh is that
right from uh yeah Georgia and then I
had one from Friendly Fire doing a
mission with one of these trainee one
zeros who fired an m79 in front of me on
a training Mission and I had shrap on my
right arm this time
well well the worst injury is I hit him
on the side of my head with the bim79
stupid don't do that
and I got to meet John Walton is that
right John Walton took the to us on my
right leg on my right right arm uh John
Walton the legendary medic Silver Star
indeed handsomest guy in in Danang and
and he died with a couple of pennies in
his pocket Sam Waltons indeed he did
what a great guy absolutely one of our
best all-time Medics and brought back
Tom Cunningham after his leg was blown
off in August 3rd in this yep oh
my God yeah so because we had uh Bob
Shipman also help later with the
Frenchman get his Purple Heart yep
because his first mission he had
shrapnel and it took us 40 years plus to
get the uh but Bob shipping and Colonel
bar and grill bar yeah they both stepped
up to the plate right and we got Doug
his Purple Heart
so it's like these Medics of Fame right
indeed so um so you go back to brag you
begin to wrap things up there how long
were you there at Brag you go with the
Sabbath group then or third no I I told
you I turned down my S and one of the
reasons I did is I wanted to go to Fort
Lewis to become a drill sergeant okay
they had openings there and I thought I
could help some of these 19 year old
idiots going into the first air cab uh
survived for a month so I got back to
brag and they said no you're going to
the division because you're still P
qualified so I spent an unhappy year in
the division hiding from all my SF
friends I should have written back to
the name and said give me my ass but and
then I would have gone to one of the
groups
I work in the first sergeant as a person
LS NCO filling out morning reports and
right waiting waiting to get out and uh
got out on August 17 went back to Philly
back to Philadelphia so where'd you go
for Nair
I went started school back the next day
I screwed up College the first time I
said another parallel I out did
you flunk out did you just quit I quit
so when we were doing uh uh burying RT
Michigan and Arlington and uh no no
we're burying Boyer Boyer and his sister
said you know my my brother started
college and it didn't work and he joined
Special Forces and I said to her there's
lots of us like that absolutely I bet
everyone 90 had been to college and
decided it wasn't working for whatever
John Walton was one of us yes but the
school he got bored on like me flunking
out and you got bored of it and said I'm
gonna go to war now yeah and you signed
up yeah did you read the book oh yeah ah
see my mother gave me a robin Moore's
book The Green Beret yeah Christmas of
1964 my senior year in high school and
that that's what got me I mean oh me too
I wanted to do that
yeah because the summer of 66 I'm
working in Yosemite dad goes hey you did
it you're out the board's gonna come
drafted literally within days I saw the
book and I was a trash man garbage man
and at during the break I've read the
book it's like that's it if I'm going to
nam I want to go with these guys exactly
because you know I had that story about
the the guy who was killed in Vietnam SF
guy he says if I get killed name a
latrine after me
and when we went to the trang I found
the latrine and used his latrine because
I wrote about it in the book right yeah
little known story they're pop probably
deserves to remain
indeed yeah
and so um of so okay you go back you go
to where'd you go to college I went back
to Temple University in Philadelphia and
uh great school and and worked and uh
went to school and just kept my head
squared away and got a degree in uh I
did
90 credits in 21 months and and uh 90 to
21 months yeah I I was I was really
embarrassed that I'd screwed up College
the first time so I
oh my God so then for near to law school
I took a year off uh drove a truck went
to Europe for a little bit and I went to
law school and met the lovely Kathy
indeed and to law school where Case
Western Reserve University in Cleveland
OH no kidding yeah
so I've been TDY in Ohio since 1970.
[Laughter]
I got a PCS to Eastern Pennsylvania
oh things to work on right projects
projects that's right that's right oh
and then um of course we've talked a
little bit about the Special Operations
Association Elden recruit you in there
he did and uh
um during these last few years other
than the coveted year that we were all
Mia because of Cove in 2020 but prior to
that
um you're on the board of directors you
put me on
it's your fault
no comment
but you're there you helped helped us
with the couple of major events which
you you know others that are familiar
with the SOA said is truly unique we had
the 2018 uh reunion which you were part
of and of course we had Bonnie Cooper
working with us and a few others Mike
Taylor Saint Bonnie the good indeed and
uh so we had that 50th anniversary to
remember and pay homage to the 16 men we
lost on August 23rd yes family some
families came out and that was for all
of us that was just a big day we had in
the 300 people in the breakfast we had
five Medal of Honor winners
five five I've forgotten and um they
never you know stood up and said hey I'm
an moh guy or anything like that those
guys didn't roll like that yeah right
the families were overwhelmed we also
did a ceremony at the wall in DC on the
exact 50th day on 23 August 2018 Dan
Thompson and I put together a ceremony
and had most of the families there Steve
Rick was there with this right and um
though it's just so sad you know the
survivor's Guild just grabs you with
those things oh yeah why why am I
standing here why wasn't I wiped out on
the first uh
in the first hours like Bill brick was
you know so it was it was it was a very
well I'm glad we did it the families
really enjoyed it we we went and made
let them know they are never forgotten
they never will be yeah because every
time they have that
um at our reunion we have that reading
for the pow Mia tables like whoa yeah
absolutely we have we did I think Phil
Devon our current Treasurer he's the
numbers guy he did the math when you
talk about
the missing soldiers from Mac V sag it's
something like 15 of our number are
still missing
we are missing something like between
the Recon teams and the uh flight Crews
about 150 the total missing from the
Vietnam war is 1500. and
maybe 300 guys on a Recon teams at any
one point right maybe yeah and they
because the numbers break down it's like
20 000 SF during the entire War Two
thousand were in SOG and out of the two
thousand depending which author you talk
to yeah five to seven hundred eight
hundred ran missions across the fence
maybe yeah
I know each author like plaster has one
number I've got one but mine always
bounced around from talking to others
and talking to our friends at dpaa right
right I was talking to Dave Maurer the
other uh
19. yeah he's and Dave just for the
record is one of those unique gentlemen
who like cleat sinyard
was in the Battle of the I drank Valley
First with first cab before he came to
Special Forces he had 900 days in
Vietnam 900 900.
and he was an outstanding one zero with
rt Louisiana sure that idiot Badger and
um
so he and I were chatting and he said
and he he wrote in my opinion the
outstanding novel you've written some
great non-fiction so oh the dying place
is classic design place it's just
classic absolutely she loves the book
and um
so he he said you ran submissions with
Eldon how many missions did you do I
said I didn't do that many I said maybe
10 maybe 15 something like that and he
says he starts laughing he said the
average guy did two to three and he says
by the way you're the only guy I know
who's not a sergeant major 100 disabled
everyone else was the sergeant major I
said I was never a sergeant major right
okay let's throw that one out I was a
shrapnel connection
[Laughter]
Dave's such a good guy he uh as you know
gave the eulogy at Eldon's funeral oh
yeah and did a wonderful job even though
he could barely hold it together sure he
did and then um
this this past year we acknowledged
those missing in action which took a lot
of work again and this is under your
tenure well we pulled it off with a good
team effort there Mike Tower did it
absolutely with Bonnie Cooper again and
they've been planning it since 19 and it
it was supposed to go forward on in 20
but covet canceled our live
participation at SOA at the store and um
the numbers by age and by covid are
dramatically renews reduce uh we we'd
hope to have a bigger crowd but it was
still a very successful event oh yeah
very successful and
as you know Mike Taylor uh not only at
the end of our store received our
highest award the Jim Butler founders
award but a few days later at the SFA
convention that a lot of us attended he
received the sfa's higher highest award
this Saint Philip Neri gold medal which
is the gold medal the gold medal so he
he picked up both of the Olympic gold
medals within with within a week I had
the opportunity and the high honor of
giving him his and uh we kept it under
wrapped there's only two people besides
the board who knew about it one was his
wife and the other was Diane Butler
Jim's Widow yeah and I asked both of
them to come up to the absolute bias to
uh to give it to him so it's a very nice
picture of Mike surrounded by his wife
and Diane Butler it's a great photo and
then just for the record for our
listeners Jim Butler was a officer Recon
um there's a couple of outstanding
stories I'm working on now with his
daughter to try to get them for the
record at some point but he ran recon at
CCM we were together there during my
second tour and then he and a few others
put together the very early first
version the Special Operations
Association was zero zero one number
yeah zero zero one Mike Taylor was a
part of that Larry Trimble was a part of
that that's right Dave Mauer Dave Maurer
was a part of that up out of Fort Evans
when they still had some troops up there
so yeah it was very interesting getting
to know Jim's Family attended the
funeral of Arlington they had a very
nice celebration of life in Carmel
before that right we had a bunch of guys
ahead and uh then we uh
the sfct helped us host a reception at
the O club for the Butler Family at the
at the internment and then we hosted
them at Sur where they got to meet a lot
of gyms mates and admirers indeed
that's uh part of our unique history
there and this really uh I don't know
I'm biased so we should any uh any other
after I forgot your law school so you
graduated from law school and then what
happens from there you begin you get it
from litigation before you became where
you're serving now yeah I was a trial
lawyer for many years and um it was your
specialty I defended people who were
sued for medical malpractice or products
liability or automobile accidents
construction cases
and about 25 years ago some judges and
lawyers asked me to start mediating
cases try to settle cases rather than
fight them and um that's that's uh the
mediation process not because of me but
because of many smarter people than me
has sort of taken over
from the Civil jury trial of resolving
civil disputes so that 99 of cases are
solved by mediation or out of court and
you avoid all that time in court that
civil cases can go for months if it can
go for years and but the the biggest
piece is the people themselves
participate in their own resolution
rather than having a jury and a judge
and uh tell them what their their
outcome is and so it's it's a very
satisfying second career for me or I'm
very happy with it and uh
as long as I keep getting calls from
lawyers and judges off and I still have
my health I'll do it and you're still
doing it you're working hard today
everybody else is retired but Doug's
turning on I I like working indeed more
fun that way
so uh we're heading down the road here
to near the end
um any reflection thoughts about your
time either in Sag before and I love the
story about how you served in SF and
then I forgot you even turned it down
they said well give it to you he said no
off
and you're in your succinct fashion we
still had a bit of an attitude then
didn't we we did yes
we're a little bit more accentuated than
mine
I'm terrifically glad that I was able to
serve with socks what a great bunch of
guys uh very interesting people
I'm very outside the box people willing
to do different things but all
concentrating on the same two missions
to accomplish the mission and and to
look to your left and look to your right
and take care of your buddy so indeed it
was a wonderful experience
D well on that note we'll come to a
close here and uh we want to again thank
Jocko willing productions for uh making
this uh Saw cast possible and we also
want to thank all the military that
protecting our country today
First Responders border patrol other
agencies that are serving our country we
also want to thank the men and women
who are online today and for those that
have served in the past and last but not
least we want to remember and salute The
Men Who were not here today
do we thank Jocko for that amen amen
airborne
Carrie welcome to the show and uh a
little post script here for uh sogcast
number 19. Doug godshaw I mean the
classic humble Soldier what a pain in
the ass to interview but what a great
guy and his stories so you're the
outsider looking into this yeah yeah
again with the the humility here
um like you say it's the the hardest
part about some of these conversations
is is these guys just you gotta pry it
out of them you know but uh just more
Amazing Stories from uh another amazing
guy on the ground with SOG just really
impressive stuff and I've ran these
missions with Elden barge well my God
and who just for our listeners Alden uh
with E4 with us at fubai in 1968 with
Doug at mylock which was just a complete
yeah and they ran missions out
of there yeah and uh so uh and Eldon was
in for 40 years wow it retired as a
two-star
um ran most of his life dedicated to
Spec Ops all the way through his career
started as enlisted became an Officer
and a Gentleman on top of it yeah went
through the ranks and uh with the Delta
Force was there for years started out as
a squad member became the squad leader
platoon leader and then the commander
for Delta Force for many years yeah his
two boys went through it gosh and he you
know
um Doug was saying he ran
13 missions with Eldon so and that was
just with his little time with Eldon how
many missions did Eldon run I know I
mean can I I can you imagine right we
just have to say that on his second tour
Duty Eldon Barnes will earn the
distinguished service cross wow during a
major firefight with the NBA including
him getting shot in the face oh my God
and the team was getting onto the
helicopter he was the last man on and
stood there with his RPD firing at the
enemy to make sure the team could get on
and get extracted now we contrast that
with the other story that we heard about
the officer being the first one off the
yeah amazing major major more being the
first one off the Hilo you know rtb
right and that's uh that's the contrast
especially from a troop you know seeing
the leader who is the first one on the
bird out in the first one stepping off
versus the last guy putting down cover
fire to make sure the team is safe and
secure on the bird and getting out of
there yeah and the other thing I you
know in talking to Doug the uh I've
heard these different stories at
different times but never together yeah
and so he's Savvy enough here I am he
gets kicked out of special forces
training but I still want to go to non
yeah he want to become mess up sure yeah
and he comes in and uh Mr modesty who
knows how many missions because knowing
him he never wrote anything down yeah he
survived August 23rd again I think the
critical point was thank God he was
drunk yeah because he and John Peters
were both there they both exited and
went their separate ways had didn't had
they gone out like Bill brick could they
have machine Gunners set up that just as
people came out like unfortunately uh
brick and the 15 others that were just
gunned down or killed in their beds with
the satchel charges that's such a tragic
uh day an event in in song history and
um every time we we hear about from one
of these gentlemen it it just
I I can't imagine I can't imagine that
that kind of uh you know having the the
one place that's semi-secure you know
that you can actually have a drink and
hang out and hang with your buddies uh
and that be that that place that haven
being violated and overrun you know it
should it's gut-wrenching a little bit
but um but yeah Doug
um
you know
did did what he thought was right in the
moment and they did they survived it
survived you know and of course we
talked about John Walton again a little
bit on that night he and Rod podlasky
were in a hooch I don't know if they've
been drinking or not but they hear the
explosions and they go we got to get out
of here and so they're debating trying
to put their shoes on yeah and they
couldn't get out the door and
um
fortunately they didn't they're a while
they're doing a debate an NBA tried to
open up the door but the door had an
extra Strong Spring on it so if you open
the door it slams shut really hard well
the NVA opened the door with the throat
of satchel charge in the door closed the
Satchel charge land and blew away the
steps gosh so when John finally John had
his shoes away for Paul Lasky to get his
act again so Polish pride and him go
running out the door there's no steps
they both fell down as the machine
gunner opened up oh my God and the
Machine Gun it was shooting where he
anticipated they would be coming down
the steps but instead they fell and they
fell beneath the fire from the machine
gun for the enemy fire because of that
Satchel charge blowing away the steps
wow yeah that's John Walton there was a
that's and Rod pawlaski incredible
incredible
um there there was one thing I thought I
caught when Doug was talking about that
night and I wanted to run it past you
and make sure I got it correct
um he said that the NBA had planted
um machine guns in the Indigent living
quarters did he did I hear that
correctly that's what he said as almost
a psyops type of
um attack to maybe try to make the
Americans suspicious of the endage does
that sound right
um I think no I think it was a dare to
kill the indige I see yeah got it and
whether it got into the hooch or not we
know as he said said I forgot the number
of ditch that we had lost that night or
we're wounded I don't even know if he
could recall either yeah I'm not sure if
there if there was if that was recorded
um in any way but just again just a
massive loss and a tragic you know
tragic event in in song history yeah and
uh
um had not Larry Trimble been up on the
mountain yeah there would have been much
higher casualties he was taking out
those mortar positions right yes yeah
and just the night you know I was just
glad I was at fubai that was a good one
to miss yeah gosh
okay
so getting back to Doug
um and you know Eldon recalled him and
said come on go to the reunion he showed
up and said hey we need somebody for the
board of directors and he was on the
board uh for at least two tours of Duty
and then he just ran for president and
he's president for next three years
fantastic and they pulled off these
events uh with the help of Mike Taylor
and the board of directors just to keep
that going you know yeah so it's amazing
service to our guys and thank goodness
for that reunion and that organization
uh bringing you gentlemen together and
oh yeah giving us the opportunity to to
hang with these guys indeed incredible
well on that note we'll close for
tonight and again uh as always we thank
Jocko willing productions for make all
this happen thank him for sending you
down here for these for these last
recordings yes sir and we look forward
to doing a song cast number 20 sometime
in the near future in the meantime as
always we thank all of our service
members the
the First Responders the border patrol
that help our country and of course the
men and women who could not be here
today and we sign off on that final
salute to all of our Mias of which there
are
1584 today in Southeast Asia from the
Vietnam War
and uh of which we have 50 Green Berets
from the seek war so we'll end on that
final salute Airborne all the way